[Music]
what's for breakfast
oh no red ball sorry mom usually makes
us eggs and Tosun and the occasional
meat well mom and here is she
whoa somebody woke up on the wrong side
of the bed and you had a choice cuz you
had the whole bed Georgie walking on
thin ice
maybe you should go across tree and
apologize I can't do that why not cuz if
I do it sets a bad precedent
what's Nixon got to do with what you
said bad president like Nixon you know
this guy you going to apologize that if
you are bring back me where's the water
come out of well seeing his ass the
dryer nowhere so this was the washer no
fooling you what are you doing
separating the whites from the colors
whoa that's racist how did I get a
rocket scientist from one son and a
rodeo clown for the other oh man I'd
give anything to be a rodeo clown they
make people happy and they see the rodeo
for free okay waters definitely on track
now I'm on delicate array it doesn't
matter just turn on it's going delicate
to be safe
nothing damn it
wait I know what to do what go across
straight and apologize to mom I'm not do
apologize for you don't have to mean it
I never do or did you just mind your
business okay sorry
Tess you're wondering I didn't mean that
see how easy it is
[Music]
hello hey were you coming back just to
get some clothes for the kids
Oh
were you coming to talk to me well yeah
I want to apologize
really
[Music]
and go for a walk talk little sure
[Music]